what's up everyone welcome we are at
Tony Robbins unleash the power within
I'm with my buddy Jim Williamson hey
what's up man thanks for coming on the
show greatly appreciate it so Jim and I
met at unleash the power within in San
Jose and we were chatting about
biohacking we were doing vas per which
both of our friends we had vas per on
the show yes have probably seen them
before
just biohacking human performance you
were teaching me about hyperbaric oxygen
chambers and all this stuff was so
interesting and then he started dropping
all this wisdom on me about energy
markets so you're the founder of Jay PTC
energy and I just want to like unpack
all of this cool stuff that you're that
you've learned and that you're bringing
to the world and hopefully we can teach
some of our peeps about what is going on
so let's maybe start with like your
fascination with energy and then we'll
do some bio hacking stuff towards the
end yes teach us about that so I started
yeah energy trading company 2005
formerly worked at calplan Corporation
which was a San Jose company for 2001
2003 and I worked for Xcel Energy which
is a utility based on a Denver we were
running three service territories which
I got a lot of good experience doing and
so got a great experience working on two
different spectrums of the market one
the regulated utility market one the
completely unregulated wholesale market
so completely different opposite
spectrums there and started my company
2005 trading virtual power which is
something that people have a fascination
with when I tell them about it it's it's
virtual power is is energy that's traded
traded in the markets where they have
these ISO is like the Kas so your your
listeners might be more familiar with
California markets or Texas or Cod
markets there's a independent system
operators all across the country and
they run these
markets where there there there
optimizing for dispatch of power on an
ongoing five-minute basis so they're
constantly solving in there and they're
solving for four problems with
congestion for instance if there's lots
of wind generation in certain pockets
and we have problems with our old
transmission infrastructure trying to
get that to the low centers without
having too much you know basically
overloading the line so okay I want to
take deep dive into this because your
professional we're gonna disseminate
this in relatable ways let's see if we
can do this come a little more into
center shot for me a little bit more
perfect that's good so because you're
the highlight so okay when we walk into
our homes our homes are running
electricity we flick on the light switch
we're pulling from the grid we are
running our fridges all day those are
pulling from the grid and our Internet's
propagating this is all coming you know
from the grid and so there's this whole
idea of optimization during certain peak
hours how are we actually getting that
energy from what sources is that coming
from sustainable like solar wind or is
that coming from burning fossil fuels
and then also you said congestion during
these hours so unpacked continue
unpacking this I just wanted to make it
that tiny bit more relatable along the
way but teach us about this energy grid
and how we're pulling from it and what
it means to be in hours of like
congestion optimization how we do that
how you're doing that
yes Lee's Marcus started in 2001 with
the the PG a niche market out in
Pennsylvania Jersey and Maryland
subsequently 2005 Midwest I also started
in the Midwest continent and then
California started to think in 2009 I
think you got Texas markets New York
New England and there's really very few
pockets in the country where there's no
competition which would be like the
southeast the Northwest which is now
changing and they're gonna integrate
into a Western grid pretty soon but so
what happens is they create these what's
called a two-term market a to settlement
market which we have a day ahead market
in a real time market so the day head
market is is what's called a financial
market and it's meant to bring roughly
ninety percent of of dollars to the to
the table and bring as much price
discovery as possible you have the
sellers which would be that the
generators and the buyers which would be
load coming to the table and entering
into the market and trying to find the
best optimisation for the next day right
so how would we know what some of the
optimizations are for the next day for
example maybe whether it might be very a
cloudy and therefore we can't get as
much solar energy it's all based on
whether it's based on user patterns
times of the day it's based on some
things that you know socioeconomic
factors like you know on the super
Monday a Superbowl load just drops off
precipitously you know you think people
would be having all these TVs on it
drive upload but what happens is people
go to other people's houses and so they
it's a load drops big time 4th of July
holiday is stuff like that so
interesting it's it's a it's a fun
holidays the load on the grid drops
because people are inside of each
other's houses yes so it's there's a lot
of things it's like this is so cool
it's a really fun it's a really it's
really fun business to be in because
it's there's just there's so much
complexity and it's just so many
different angles to approach it from so
it's a it's a data miners dream
it's it's it's really fun stuff but what
happens is that you have all these
different mixtures of resources right
you got coal old coal generation you got
hydro you've got wind's you've got
nuclear you've got gas you've got
peaking gas you've got oil and all these
have all kinds of different qualitative
or you know restrictive restrictions on
their use so for instance a combined
cycle gas power plant 500 megawatt to
buy one to two gas turbine one steam
turbine power plant would maybe have a
minimum run time of 16 hours so if it's
coal on the run it's they're saying hey
I'll run but you need I need to run 16
hours so those are all kinds of
restrictions like that ramp rate
restrictions and all kinds of things
like that so the challenge with these
markets is that you always have to match
supply and demand
you always have to maintain 60 Hertz
there's no fudge room there you can't
you know we don't have any you know any
viable storage right now you know
battery technology is coming along but
it's it's I find it as a as a as a
former submarine guy that least work on
batteries storage batteries some of the
base batteries we've ever made I find
that to be a hard nut to crack because
it's it's a it's a big problem
so I there's things that you know
there's in California got pumped storage
hydropower
[Music]
but you have a pump storage unit which
is basically is a battery where you have
a lower reservoir and upper reservoir
right and so at night the water is up
from the lower reservoir is pumped up
and they're pumping you know they're
drawing load from the grid but they're
drawing it usually at times of low
prices when you get one typically more
wind generation prices are low and so
you might be saving up at a price of $10
a megawatt off-peak hit and night to the
upper reservoir and then subsequently
during the middle of the day whenever
the prices are highest you might be
spilling it's $100 $100 doesn't Wow okay
so can we also maybe make this a
relatable example could potentially be
also
that I have battery storage at my house
and that I pull from the grid in the
middle of the night when it's cheap and
then during the day I'm not using my
energy so I sell it back off to the grid
can I can I can we make money so you're
starting it's happened so one of my
ideas that Tony's giving me so we were
at business mastery 2 in Rotterdam a
couple weeks ago okay and Tony always
has this question he says what business
are you in which to me he's always
simple I go in there and like I'm an
energy trader so I'm trying to get some
other qualitative you know improvements
on my myself as a business person and so
forth but for me you know when it comes
to the business I don't how many sales
people I don't how many customers per se
I interact I interact strictly with the
markets but it's so interesting almost
everybody in Silicon Valley has
customers and has like a product or a
service that they give to customers so
when somebody goes I don't have products
or I don't have customers but I have but
and what I do is I only work mostly with
markets that's a very interesting new
like 1% or less of people that we engage
with do just that it's it's a it's great
to not have that stress don't have a
boss and I don't have customers yeah so
but what Tony asses is he says you know
what business are you in and then what
business do you really need to be in you
know and so I started thinking about
that's kind of the Peter Thiel question
is how can you monopolize in what
business do you need to be in the one
that nobody else is thinking about they
so on I have a big idea and and it kind
of tops on my experience in the in the
power markets as a power plant operator
myself and ends and seeing we're seeing
where we're going in the 21st century
with with we're in 24 century right so
so it's like daylight savings time so
we're moving to smart homes smart
controls roughly we make it to the 22nd
century
so it had a lot of things come in ahead
of us with AI in robotic so we got to
figure out yeah so so we were moving
towards automation and intimate or
towards smarter controls right yes so
I've been talking to you know even even
in the 20 Robinson's fear with this
Platinum Partners group and others
meaning some you know developers that
are very forward-thinking that is in
Peter diamond is talking about this
quite a bit with energy yeah he spoke
about this at the finance conference or
in Sun Valley
yeah so we're looking at you know
residents say we have a residential
development of a thousand homes okay now
we let's say we wire these all together
to a central computer now you know you
have privacy concerns stuff like that
but what we're really trying to do is is
get their power in power and heating and
cooling needs served in the most
reliable way or in the most efficient
way right so let's say my easy example
here is is that you you go to work you
load the dishwasher or you push a button
you don't need to have the dishes washed
immediately especially if you don't need
them an hour later and you can wait
until energy costs a lot less and water
costs a lot less yes same thing for hot
water heaters same thing for air
conditioning so think about this yes so
think about this you've got you know
when you come home from work you know
whatever time it is you just want to
make sure that your tip your house is
not too hot like let's say it can't be
any hundred seventy seven degrees or 76
degrees whatever so you any kind of
flexibility you have in the consumption
of load is an opportunity to to is
create efficiencies there were let's say
you pre cool the house say at 6:00 in
the morning 7:00 the morning or when you
go to work and you cool down say 265
degrees which you might think would be
thing but interesting super price now
this is all pretty this all pretty good
day it's gonna get hot but you've
already taken from the grid during the
night when it was less expensive and
cooled it down on your way out and this
all presupposes that you're exposed to
retail rates that's a big qualifier
there right it under the whole I'm sorry
wholesale race so this all presupposes
that so you know if you're able to
respond to those those wholesale prices
in real time
this is crisis enormous if opportunities
at when you when you start grouping
these in a thousand home and a thousand
homes or industrial and so forth when
you create portfolios of efficiencies
like that or I'm sorry when they're out
of the house just don't you tap into the
grid or maybe tap in like we were
talking about at night to fill up and
then sell back to the grid during the
day when it's people there's also
opportunities so there's people don't
understand this but there's a lot of
times when there's all that parts of the
country where depending on the first
winds or so forth you know whatever
there is constraints for transmission
outages or power plan outages there's a
lot of places where where prices are
negative so we're talking about places
where it's certain places we want you
consume as much demand as possible cuz
you're getting paid to consume load okay
you were teaching me about this a couple
months back and it was blowing my mind
okay so when we're looking at an energy
map we're looking at energy map and we
see that in Oklahoma there's either
there's these numbers and they can
either be positive or negative numbers
okay so then you can either get you
either have to pay to get energy from
the grid or there are times when they
have a lot of energy that you can get
paid to take the energy when prices go
negative you're getting paid to consume
load so you want consume as much as
possible so an example this is would be
Google set up a server farm up there
north of Omaha okay on the border
between Nebraska and Iowa they applied
for wholesale market rates and so they
at any given time if prices go negative
which they often do in Iowa with a lot
of wind generation they have their if
prices go negative if they go blunt to
certain points but need certain
threshold they can instantly shift
worldwide query traffic to this server
center and max out there because
basically they're getting paid to draw a
load as much I mean if they can
consummate any more law in paying for
this right and this and these prices all
change every five minutes right so
there's a big opportunity here snow now
what I've been this is so mind blowing
holy cow wow so you can set up and this
is not only applies to servers but this
applies just you know to especially
right now decentralization push for
blockchain for mining and this this has
so many being able to relocate you know
the tractor-trailer you know with with
you know one of the graphics is GPUs
right you're you're just sucking down as
much as possible yeah and you're getting
paid because like the place like Iowa
has a lot of wind energy at that time
and you're getting paid now why no no
here's a quick question why wouldn't I
will keep their generator filled up to a
hundred percent and not pay you to suck
from it but why wouldn't they just keep
it in and not pave what it's not lose
them by remember again remember they
have to keep sixty Hertz so they yeah
wind turbines that are online and
they're and they're pumping out power
let's say there's a lot of winds okay
now think about this otherwise they'd
have to turn it off is which typically
you think that they would turn off when
the prices got to zero otherwise they're
having to pay yeah what what happens is
most of wind farms are turning off only
when prices get to like negative thirty
seven dollars a megawatt that negative
thirty seven dollars megawatt coincides
with the substitute you're getting
pulled you're getting paid thirty seven
bucks a megawatt so they they are yes
yes so at negative thirty seven dollars
there it gets to a point of pain where
they you know say it's negative forty
dollars now they're losing three dollars
in megawatt because they get thirty
seven dollars in subsidies oh the
subsidies and tax credits yeah
Oh interesting okay so at negative 37
they'll keep selling energy because even
though you get paid 37 bucks that acts
as a subsidy okay and that's subsidized
by taxpayer dollars and then as and then
once it gets to negative 40 then they're
actually losing $3 per day so all all
generators in the mark all the wind
generators in the market at least in the
Midwest and I think most of the other is
oh is they stop they have the ability to
feather their blades so it at that at
that points they feather their blades
now and they and they stop pretty much
so this would be on a really windy day
and you're seeing wind turbines and
you're like why are they not working
yep that's what happens if it's you know
cool knob wrench load or this case or
this there's kind of congestion
sometimes it could be a lot of demands
in cities and that creates a lot more
pull you know across the transmission
lines yeah all these wind render if you
do have wind and it's hot which is rare
you typically wind is inversely
proportional to Sun right
whereas solar is directly proportional
Sun so there's there's a lot of
different features to these green
technologies which are you know there
are the going to a grid planning hydro
for instance I've always said that pump
storage hydropower in tanana's country
and we're lagging behind sorely the US
Army Corps of Engineers I think early
last year maybe your before that
published report were I think they
identified 52 sites in the country 52
hydro sites were it would be some simple
reengineering and minimal planning to
basically create take a run of river
hydro unit which basically means you got
you know water coming down the river or
you got a dam and they release and they
never capture it going back up to be
able to pump up to the to the upper
reservoir ground again
or above the dam and be able to do that
full cycle so 52 sites where you have
pump storage so we're trying to make it
cost less energy to move the water up
than we get from it running down so it
basically gives you that that battery
component where you're you're you're
you're capturing the Delta between
off-peak prices and and on peak prices
and that see what happens at night it's
really hard for the grid operator
sometimes to manage the grid because
there's so much wind and we've got old
generators a lot of these cold coal
generators or say running at $17 a
megawatt and they're trying to get these
things down as fast as I can but a lot
of these older units are having problems
they they're just they don't move very
fast anymore they have equipment
problems they got boiler tube leaks when
you start cycling them off and on so
they're trying to get everything off
they can so a pump storage unit is a
goldmine for an operator because they
can suck power at some times negative
prices so you're getting paid to consume
load again pump it up to the upper
reservoir and now you're made again and
then you can store in your battery that
energy yeah that is so interesting Wow
okay whoa so I'm pulling dam I'm pulling
from the grid at an at valve and naked
there's a negative price I'm getting
paid to pull pumping that water up and
then I'm storing the electricity that I
generate from the water rolling back
down you can actually regulate the
pumping so if you if you could have
advanced controls in these pumps now you
can you can float the system which is
important to get regulation need to be
able to to control sixty Hertz on the
system right so it can regulate at night
which is another tough thing for I got
the operator to do is to find some kind
of variable resources that can you know
dispatch up and down at a moment's
notice but you know I've kind of
portrayed the grid as being excessively
finicky and and crazy on negative prices
and positive right like it's it's very
it's the most fun to market it's the
most dynamic to volatile markets in the
world
and it is the most dynamic and volatile
in the world oh by far by far so but but
here's what and like you said weather
affects it tremendously that's it but
here's why so it's not just that the
absolute level of crisis just was
insanely high insanely low it's really
what's going on is is that the grid
operator is is operating the grid in the
most reliable manner it can so if you
remember the blackout of 2003 shut down
the entire Eastern grid there was power
lines that were had overhanging branches
in Akron Ohio and one of them tripped
and that caused a parallel line to get
overloaded because power follows the
path of least resistance Ohm's law and a
lot of stuff you know and so powerful it
falls the path of least resistance so
power is going from a generator to load
it's got much of one cuts off then it
follows and not that overloads and when
does it when can we put in these safety
supposed to be operated that way but
with with the what the grid operator
does in real time every five minutes
what they're doing is they they
basically say they go through a
contingency analysis and it's called the
n minus one contingency analysis and so
what they say is is that they're gonna
go through tens of thousands of lines
and it takes you know pretty fast
computers do this and be able to
sequentially open lines they they open
up a line Reese all for the power flow
and say okay did it cause a violation on
another line okay no so go the next one
next one next to the next one if they
finds a line that if they if they open
it and it causes a violation which means
it's overloading a component that's
transformer a line then they literally
in the next solution they assume that
lines out even though it's not out they
just say okay we're gonna pretend this
out and we're gonna solve for a power
flow solution where in the next five
minutes we need to get resources on on
the far side of this constraint so
they're gonna raise generation on the
far side they're gonna reduce it on the
near side so they're gonna reduce the
amount of flow so that's in a post
contingent scenario there's less flow
across it and so it won't exceed the
limits on
that that's a monitor device and so this
is happening all over the place and
there's a grid as it credibly can
complex' right see we don't even think
about this twice when we walk in and
flick on the light switch or we have the
fridge running all day it's why we have
the most reliable grid in the world III
just and we consume 25% of the world's
energy and we only have 5% of the
world's people
yeah I just moved to Puerto Rico and it
rained the other day and the rain comes
we lose power the the Sun comes out we
don't lose power with the power comes
back it rains again for those crazy it's
it's it's it you can't even have
refrigeration then well we have backup
generator generator but it's the
generators coming on it's transferring
and the power comes back and transfers
back it's just it's not so could you
imagine living like that no well yeah it
is actually in Puerto Rico they got so
much going for them in other other ways
but think about how much that takes away
from our cognitive ability to be
creative or be innovative because one of
the main reasons why we can be so
creative and innovative today's because
we don't have to be so concerned about
Owens the energy gonna turn off I'm
gonna have to dedicate an hour of my
time to fixing the energy issue in front
of my face you're telling us about where
your business needs to be and there's
all of these different fluctuations that
go on the grid with the pricing the
weather prediction optimization so
you're figuring out how to write
software and machine learning to really
figure out the most optimal optimization
for this yeah what it is though is it's
uh you know solving for the power flow
on on a grid is actually pretty easy
because they they take a very complex AC
problem alternating current problem
where you've got capacitances and
inductances and circulating currents all
this stuff it's very complex
especially on a grid on a massive grid
but we dumb it all down the grid the
grid operator dumps it all down and they
assume a DC current
it's problem so now we're talking
basically on water you know for you
engineers out there sorry uh mechanical
engineers like water flowing through
pipes right so it's just simple pressure
problem so it's it's very simple problem
but it's currently incredibly complex
the problem is now we're gonna for every
input solution we have let's say we
assume a certain amount of load a
certain amount of wind wind generation
certain you know certain weather in
certain areas generated availability
transmission line availability
that's one input based case input now
you've got tens of thousands of
contingencies to run around that so if I
want to run through a lot of
probabilistic scenarios here on what I
think weather might do or what weather
winds will show up you know two hours
early or two hours late or more wind or
less wind than forecast or the weather
is you know hotter or colder than
forecast all these things are things
that's any kind of you know odds maker
would do in Vegas and that's kind of
what my job is is it I'm trying to run
through and determine since the overall
end end result is gonna I'm looking for
sensitivities and so the grid operators
currently don't have the capability to
solve for this they they run as a
deterministic set point so they they
take all these inputs
take a load forecast a wind forecast
generation availability and take all
these inputs and they run it as a line
in the sand these are the inputs they're
gonna solve as it's a complex solution
in the name and they solve they
basically publish a plan for the next 24
hours
these units should be on these these
units should be off and so they publish
that and that's it but what happens is
they have a day ahead plan and then in
real-time as a fifth was called the
physical market real-time happens and
things go all over the place and it's a
so the grid is a living breathing
monster if you look at it yeah the the
powerful is moving all over the place of
wind generations moving all of places
it's it's it's it's constantly moving
constantly in flux so it's almost enough
it's absolutely it never actually
happens where
the real-time you know real-time happens
the way they had was planned so what I
what I realized is that is that with
these advanced controls and are moving
into the future if we're going to really
do better at optimizing the way we
consume load countrywide nationwide I
feel like one of the best outputs for my
business one of the tertiary outputs
besides just trading power is to provide
an index if you will for for control you
know basically residential or industrial
demand to be able to forecast there the
power prices in the next hour to 24
hours maybe 36 hours we can always they
can always respond to the prices in real
time it's pretty simple as prices are
high you don't consume load if prices
are low you can zoom load that's pretty
easy but we're not something I like you
know like a monkey can do that but we're
talking about like being able to go into
the future here and kind of plan like
you know pre-cooling your house you know
if I if I consume load it's 7:00 in the
morning when I'm let's say I go to work
at sell in the morning now we're gonna
cool the house down to 62 degrees
yeah we're to freeze you out but prices
are 25 dollars a megawatt afternoon
prices go up to hundred dollars a
megawatt correct now you got a pre cold
house and you got to consume less you
don't need to consume as much load
during those hours to cool the house
down you still come back to a house
that's less than 75 degrees 77 degrees
will say depending on your preferences
but the the flexibility that's any the
flexibility and your consumption of the
load aggregated on a portfolio basis on
a massive scale can be huge you know it
cities can do this if you're exposed to
wholesale prices and you can react to
this there's a lot of opportunities you
know to capture the Delta between
morning prices afternoon prices and so
forth so and then B of cities like you
said to and being able to forecast of
congestion you know there's there can be
congestion based on certain pockets you
know there's certain pockets of cities
let's say that with a transmission
outage that happened
maybe on the forecast or not forecast
you want them consume consume as much
power as possible
so it's literally the they're having
problems optimizing the grid without it
so I have access to wholesale prices I
have a city of a hundred thousand houses
and I want to optimize the energy
consumption for the houses so I figure
out that if someone's leaving like you
said in the morning that you can cool
the house down right away after they
leave that optimizes the cooling in the
home then also the maybe in the morning
or at night you've also taken a lot of
energy from the grid and stored it and
then during the day you're using it
you're selling it so there's all of this
that can be optimized through software
and through forecasting so you're the
three different kinds of generators
Micro generators let's say and roof I
mean you've got the ability to store
some some power not just electrical
power and batteries let's say but but
you know mechanical power or hydro
mechanical power like you know hot water
heaters pressurized systems stuff like
that you have the ability to to
discharge that whenever you need to to
be able to generate later on whenever
the prices are higher okay so these are
the advanced communities lit you know
which we're moving to is will be you
know they might have micro micro
generators on-site you might have the
ability to store power I just feel like
they're gonna be they're gonna need to
have that information they you know to
to be able to to make the decisions they
need to make advanced communities and
understanding better energy use in those
advanced communities awesome it's so
interesting that that's where the
business is going I want to make sure we
also talked about subsidies because that
was so interesting that what you were
describing about $37.00 subsidies so
taxpayer dollars go to energy subsidies
for clean energy wind/water/solar and
that's much water right now
I wish it wouldn't but it's not and and
so then these subsidies go to the let's
take a wind farm as an example so
there's a wind farm and the wind farm if
the grid is a negative thirty seven
let's say it's negative thirty and so
then you pull from the grid
you get paid thirty dollars they keep
seven dollars and this and the only
reason this happens is because the
government's giving them thirty seven
dollars per megawatt hour yes so what
it's done I think is it's it's really
changed the the grid as far as what's
economic and what's not and you've had
historically economic generators and
some some generators like to say nuclear
units that are closer well
closer than wind to historical load
centers that are no longer economic
because power prices are so low in a lot
of us due to the wind generations so you
got areas which they can't survive on
getting revenue from the real time
energy markets the capacity markets
aren't structured very well so they're
not getting any credit for their ability
to provide capacity you know the wind
generator you know the American Wind
Association says well we should get
credit for capacity but I can tell you
from experience operating a grid they're
not there whenever you got your highest
slows of the summer if you've got hot
weather at the highest you got a plan
for the the worst-case scenario right if
you're gonna maintain energy security in
this country so you can't plan for a you
know we can't hope right can't can't
hope that everything lines up and we
have enough wind or enough solar at any
given time we have to have you know
enough of a diversification in our
portfolio where we have a reasonable
very good likelihood that we're gonna be
able to cover all of our bases so what
ends up happening is in the summertime
you it's if it's 100 degrees outside
typically you're not getting a lot of
wind generation it's just they just
don't they don't work that way so
typically get a lot of more different
generation at night there's great times
in the in the shoulder periods of spring
and fall where you get a lot of
generators on outage where when
you know when it's very helpful its its
economic it's it's doing its thing but I
think it's we've got I think we've kind
of overloaded ourselves on one side of
things you know we got too much wind
I think Solar has its purpose but I just
for me personally this is my opinion I
think it'd be better to see if solar on
top of rules you know the shingles like
what Elon Musk it was fantastic it's
just gonna it's gonna power the home
it's can power the car some brilliant
stuff so and you can salt back to the
grid it's all very interesting but also
I do have to say that concentration of
solar is also very interesting
so like the two angle all the solar up
until that main massive pillar structure
that then has the molten salt running
through it and yeah thing is crazy
really high that gives a really high
energy output right yeah I'm a pilot and
I've flown over that thing a few times
it is bright I mean there's a couple
around the world that are from satellite
views they look crazy but yeah it can
blind they can fry birds there's all
this kind of crazy stuff yeah but okay
so tell us because you were going into
the musk and shingles but I just I just
want to know on the subsidy side of
things is this this is good in long term
or or is it more nuanced how can it be
better this is my personal opinion again
so I I just feel like personally I from
my economics classes I feel like you
know we should assign a socio-economic
costs to pollution to any kind of factor
we want to add but I would like to see
markets price them and let the markets
decide what's most economic in any given
time so if if wind generation you give
it a credit like give it a dollar per
megawatt credits and we can calculate
what those costs are what those benefits
are if pollution on a coal generator for
removing so2 or or NOx gases is
you know X number of dollars let's
assign them a penalty factor and then
it's easy to now let everything just
kind of the chips fall and we can
optimize very easily when we do things
where we kind of attacks pollutions good
yeah
absolutely so it drives it drives the
proper behavior so we need people around
the world on the same page about that
because if one country is polluting
egregiously while the other one is
taxing well the country that's polluting
egregiously can take economic they can
be overly malicious to the Earth's
sustainability just so they can
economically prosperous I can advantage
yeah this is Morgan I think to the point
of this is more local and it's hard to
it's a different problem I guess me
trying to solve for for macro you know
the worldwide kind of pollution effects
but and yeah and you could affect it as
well but but what happens is when you
when you just give it a brunt force you
know say X number of dollars per
megawatts production tax credits what it
does is it it drives other generators
out of the market because it's with yeah
when we drift away here so so when when
you when you when you what those are
called out of market costs or benefits
is that in the price can't the market
can't solve that and and what happens is
you get generators that otherwise
economic that they can't they can't run
in those markets and they get eventually
priced out and they have to shut downs
and and then lo and behold after 10
after the 10-year point the production
tax credit for a wind farm expires and
now what we see is these these wind
farms go from negative 47 dollar per
megawatt offer to zero which makes sense
because if they generate they'll make
some money if they don't then or if they
you know then they don't wanna they want
to generate when they're losing money
right is it safe to say that without a
subsidy on
wind and solar energy that people would
want to pull from fossil fuel sources
because it's cheaper I'm sorry it's so
you if there wasn't a subsidy for wind
and solar energy that we would pull
electricity from fossil fuel faster
because or more because it's cheaper no
actually what happens is is that the
lowest priced fossil fuel generation
ends up being coal
typically Powder River Basin coal which
would be like say seventeen dollars
megawatt all in to the market and
beneath that you've got fixed generation
which can't respond to dispatch so it
doesn't matter nuclear generation that's
gonna run if it runs because it with
coal it would cost me seventeen dollars
a megawatt hour to buy it
yes wind how much does it cost
well wind is you know free right if you
sign if you assume that so I mean you
have operation and maintenance cost
which you know in a front cause the
dollar may well I'm not sure but but the
fact is is that between seventeen
dollars megawatt and zero there's
nothing in there that's gonna move
besides wind so it really doesn't matter
whether they have a subsidy or not if
they didn't have a subsidy they'd still
be the most efficient resource on the
grid it's almost like it's just it's
just blowing my mind cuz I'm literally
envisioning setting up one wind turbine
and then just having the free wind to
come and power versus like taking and
lugging call and burning it and lugging
coal and burning it just doesn't make
any sense income so there's so many
nuances to this that people see what
I've learned I I got an amazing
experience working on the desk at Xcel
Energy I was a day head analyst running
the Colorado subsystem public service
company of Colorado and optimizing
running the models looking at our
opportunity cost whether we should
buying or selling off the grid setting
our pricing for those and determining
which units should run which wouldn't
which ones shouldn't and you know
it was a great job and then doing the
same thing up in Minnesota Wisconsin
Northern States power well what what I
learned is is that there are times you
know we've there's always room for
nuance so here we go the Black Swan yes
so you know what's what's you know you
got a plan for fact things that you
could never imagine
okay 2013 I think we had a huge freeze
and Texas okay
and all these generators just got wiped
out and they had freeze meaning they had
a hard freeze yet it was I think it's a
rainstorm event or something like that
we basically had you had a precipitation
event and extremely cold temps which
caused a lot of units to shut down they
weren't ready for it they didn't have
they didn't take precautions for all
kinds of various things he doing a coal
plant but basically they lost a lot of
base load generation and so they had
rotating blackouts so let's think little
thing about this so in the wintertime in
cold places will say northern you know
say Minnesota or New England or anywhere
in Colorado let's say you've got gas
plants that are only getting their gas
after consumers the residential
customers get their gas and so typically
gas generation is further down the
pipeline than residential gas and so
there's times when when it gets really
really cold let's say negative ten
degrees in Colorado and they give twenty
five degrees and Minneapolis st. Paul
when you they curtail you so powerplant
says power plant is getting more gas so
now they have to shut down now what's
gonna run well I'll tell you that you
know you're not getting any you might
get wind generation that there's a
fossil fuel so what the the ability to
store um well the nuance comes another
month
yeah let's say a coal plant has Paulie a
month month and a half of coal sitting
on a pile yeah and in that energy
security is invaluable it's interesting
it's absolutely just in case otherwise
it can be really bad if the grid has to
turn
off that hole you can't pull energy
because there is no when there is no
solar there's interesting I mean there's
obviously it cool there's varying levels
of coal obviously you know I worked for
Kalpana and weari operated the cleanest
fleet of natural gas for our generation
in the country and so and I could talk
about this for so long I know and and I
and I want to make sure that we touch a
bit on your biohacking interests as well
because this is super fascinating on the
way out because this is already the
really interesting complicated and
nuanced interview on energy markets and
it's been super enriching and we've
dived into a lot of good alleys let's
talk a bit about your bio hacking on the
way out so we can also not go super long
on the interview and I'll also chop this
up into bits as well and circulate those
so on the bio hacking side of things
teach us about this the hyper oxygen
hyperbaric oxygen chamber so we have
like 21% of the atoms here are oxygen
and we're inhaling that to circulate
blood in our body to power our body and
so what does hyperbaric it's a
concentration of it and then how do I
feel do I feel like
ah this is really about not just oxygen
it's about oxygen under pressure so
oxygen under pressure is a drug and it's
a drug that turns on off 6,000 up to
6,000 genes in your body whoa it's it's
it's incredible so there's a book
written by dr. harsh who is the world's
leading expert
down in Louisiana it's called the the
oxygen revolution I read it it's
incredible I think it's a must read for
anybody that has any kind of element
but what what ended up happening was I
for any ailment it could do rejuvenate
let me let me let me qualify that so
it's so let me back that download so it
can do incredible things I don't want to
oversell it there's so many more things
they can do that we realize and we're
gonna get to that point so what dr. Hart
has done he he kind of partnered
pioneered this stuff in 90s and and it
was kind of labeled I'm not sure it kind
of like maybe what's chiropractors were
labeled by the Medical Association back
in the day we're just starting to now
kind of come to a real sense of
acceptance on what the the benefits of
that are or maybe now it's acupuncture
what does act is it is it a fringe thing
has it have any benefit or is it just
entertainment value so so when it comes
to hyperbaric oxygen so dr. harsh fought
and fought fought he he basically
realized he's working with people he was
work with divers Navy divers and
typically how to break oxygen was
something that was only used for you
know to cure divers that had the bends
and and so forth so but he you started
realizing I do so much more and so he's
did a lot of testing he came late a lot
of evidence and a lot of data SPECT scan
data from the brain like showing you the
blood flow in the brain showing quality
you know quantitatively what's going on
in the brain whenever you do this
therapy would he would he ended up
getting he got a lot of pushback from
the medical associations and the
insurance companies and so forth trends
so I guess a lot of people were saying
you know hyperbaric oxygen could do all
kinds of things and it was you know he's
trying to keep it very narrow in focus
because he doesn't want to be labeled
this pressurizing Oh - yeah so oxygen
it's basically there's different levels
of it so you got you know and it felt a
lot of these NFL players or athletes
will have and I have myself actually a
a semi-rigid pressure vessel in your
house it mines like a can of canvas type
container and it's pretty comfortable
get in but it's your you basically have
93% option coming off of a oxygen like
you see at the at the at the nursing
home
right it ends is it tank it's not I
actually have one that's it's one of
those I'm losing my wander so it's like
one of those it's called a little
machine they're lucky you might see it
at a doctor's office sure sure
but and then you can control the oxygen
output from it yes it's a place about 90
to 93 percent and it's you'll see Matt
nursing homes and so forth and then
you're sitting in a closed room so you
can increase the oxygenation of the room
no this is actually in a tube so it's
it's I get in I get in this big tube and
it's and it's got a little bit in there
and pillow and it's got windows and
stuff and I and so you zip it up it's
got some pleats and stuff and then it is
a double stage compressor and it
pressures up pressure rises up like 1.3
atmospheres which is about the
equivalent of being 12 feet under water
pressure whoa what is what happens to
the body when you're like laying at 1.3
so what happens is it you press your
fears you know you'll equalize and do it
to this certain pressure where you you
stay steady state does it feel good on
your bones and your muscles
I wouldn't say bones so forth but I just
I lay in there and I work I relaxed so
it's it's not an explosive environment
it's lower oxygen state so no medical
grade oxygen would be a hundred percent
oxygen in a hospital and like to say up
to three atmospheres of pressure that's
that's an environment where you can't
even have a wool shirt on you know you
don't wanna have any kind of sparking
going on in there so okay but so what's
the benefit of when you're inhaling so
what happens is your red blood cells are
able to absorb your cap I think is your
red blood cells are able to absorb up to
10 percent more oxygen
then we're breathing right now say near
sea level and an auction but what
happens is your your plasma is able to
absorb seven hundred to a thousand
percent I think in excess of seven
hundred percent more oxygen your plasma
is smaller than your red blood cells
your plasma typically is transported
further and now we're getting in dr.
realms room I don't sure there's any
doctors listening I don't but you can
your red blood cells are able to carry
10% more oxygen isn't that much more but
your plasma well your plasma can carry
eight seven hundred percent more like a
lot more so that's huge yeah so what
ends up happening is it's carrying
oxygen to every crevice in your body
every that ever the furthest expanses
your body and you feel really good very
well yeah you do feel really good as I
practice deep breathing in there if for
nothing else if you didn't believe in
anything this thing does it's get in
there and I do some deep breathing and
it's great and it's relaxing so I get in
there a network but what happens is it
you're you're you're getting blood flow
to places in your body that doesn't see
it very often you know or you might as
we get older II older you might have
some injuries or some what dr. Hart's
labels as a as a flight to the body or a
insult to the body where you've got
parts of your brain that might be a
little bit restricted in blood and a lot
of love there a lot of people hurt
they're near their back yeah a lot of
neurological conditions or I guess
basically they're did they come down to
a restriction in blood flow direction of
blood flow interesting so what I read in
dr. Carter's book which kind of hit me
was a he thinks that every ambulance
some day we'll have hyperbaric oxygen
chamber in the ambulance because as an
example a stroke patient can completely
recover from all effects of a stroke if
they get into a chamber within the net
within the hour
damn can I'm not saying they will that's
interesting so and there's a bunch of
other things when it comes to you know
traumatic brain injuries that vapor
barrack oxygen can help with
neurological issues from a brain injury
stroke issue this is so PTSD is actually
symptom eyes I guess the one of symptoms
of PTSD is this it causes a swelling of
the brain inflammation is wreaking in
the brain a shrinking yeah that's what
it is it's it's it's I was I'm reading
all this a lot of doctors talks to
psychedelics helps with PTSD as well
yeah so I just I was fascinated with
this book and I actually bought my
oxygen chamber as I was giving it I was
gonna give it to a soldier that suffered
a traumatic ranging brain injury and his
parents weren't quite comfortable that
he was gonna be able to get out of the
chamber quick enough so they actually
went to dr. Hart's directly and he is
you want to talk about a miracle this
kid is close to doing his 80th dive I
think in the past six months and he is
gone from nearly a basically a vegetable
so now sitting up feed himself singing
talking it's incredible 80th dive into
hyperbaric oxygen dive is basically
maybe an hour hour and a half he's about
an hour and he used to be paralyzed
no not paralyzed but basically a
vegetable vegetable eyes and couldn't
move his entire brain or half of his
brain caved in oh my gosh and then was
able to move dance sing etc yeah it's it
could also be very helpful for veterans
like you said so which is crucial when
they come back that they are able to
reintegrate into communities and
societies maximally Wow yeah so the the
the thing is is that the strap up now so
this is probably the the Veterans
Administration the VA finally started
looking at this getting a lot of
pressure from their constituents and the
the senators and all that stuff
basically the VA did a study which was a
faulty were they they insisted on having
a control group so you have people you
know getting oxygen under pressure but
they said well the control group you
have to have a chamber under pressure
because if they weren't pressurized and
didn't feel with the ears
than they they would know that there
they were yeah so the thing is though
when you get a chamber under pressure
you go from 21 percent oxygen and if
it's alessia's you're bringing them up
to 1.5 atmospheres now you're up to
thirty percent oxygen yeah and so they
were getting there both groups are
getting benefits and they basically said
well we statistically can't prove that
it's enough of an improvement on the
oxygen under pressure it's interesting
when you can't manage a control like
that so it just it's gonna be someday
the they're gonna get this this therapy
I know it's gonna happen and dr. harsh
has gotten so many different treatments
approved for reimbursement from the
insurance companies like you know
diabetic foot wounds right I think he
saves like 70,000 limbs a year now
because though being reimbursed diabetic
yeah because it cut off circulation to
that part of the body and then you can
reinvigorate circulation with hyperbaric
oxygen Wow okay so you're ahead of your
time with hyperbaric oxygen I think you
know Vow friends have asked for our head
of their time there's so many of these
biohack ER hackers and bio hacking in
general that you know Tony's a big fan
of as well as you are and so many other
people that we've had on the show energy
markets what an incredible dive into
energy markets as well I feel so much
more understanding of the nuance of it I
only know point zero zero one percent
more but it's it's so important to
understand where our energy actually
comes from and also how to maximize
energy across the world because energy
does increase the standard of living and
maximizes people's potential into the
world Jim what an absolute pleasure
thank you thanks for coming on to the
show I'm love Jim's links in the bio
definitely go check it out if you guys
had a good time with what you learned
definitely go share some of the
knowledge you've learned with two other
people about energy markets or
biohacking go and take that and go share
it don't just consume this content go
create with it make videos make blog
posts go write about it go make videos
about it start companies in it etc also
join us on patreon we need to continue
sustaining this project and growing it
impacting more people doing more live
events getting to the sports day and so
join us there links
the bio as well thanks everybody and
we'll see you soon